[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: WELL, IT WAS THE FIRST
WEEKEND OF THE NFL SEASON WHICH
EXPLAINS WHY YOU'RE ALL
STILL HUNGOVER AND YOUR DAD'S
YELLING AT YOU.
IN HONOR OF FOOTBALL RETURNS,
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS #NFLRAPERS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE, FAT JOE
MONTANA, TUPAC CONVERSION.
OR DR. DRE WILL TREAT YOUR
CONCUSSION NOW.
HE'S NOT A REAL DOCTOR.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO! YES, JAY.
>> WILL I AM PLEADING NO
CONTEST.
CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS.
YES, RANDY.
>> LITTLE DREW BREEZY.
CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS. YES, JAY.
>> MARKY MARK SANCHEZ AND THE
FUNKY BUNCH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. BRANDON.
>> THE TENNESSEE T.I. TITANS.
CHRIS: NICE. OH, YEAH, GOOD.
POINTS. RANDY.
>> RED ZONE THUGS AND HARMONY.
CHRIS: OKAY. ALRIGHT.
FINE.
JAY.
>> LIL JON FOOTBALL.
CHRIS: OH -- I'LL ALLOW IT.
POINTS.
IT JUST MADE IT IN. -- RANDY.
IT JUST HIT THE UPRIGHT AND
BOUCNED IN. RANDY.
>> HOW ABOUT EMINEMETT SMITH.
CHRIS: OKAY. GOOD, YEAH, I LIKE
IT. BRANDON.
>> L.L. COOL JAY CUTLER.
CHRIS: OH GOOD. POINTS.
>> HE'S GOT A BAD KNEE!
CHRIS: JAY,
>> YOUNG DREW BREEZY.
TWISTED IT!
CHRIS: MAKES YOU THINK.
BRANDON.
>> NFLWA.
CHRIS: OKAY, GOOD. POINTS.